gosta do nordestino reclamando de calor
viu porque quando o nordestino vem
reclamar de calor é porque tá quente viu
Major agora também quando faz frio vou
lhe dizer viu tu é doido primeira dica
que eu cheguei em São Paulo tava tão
frio tão frio que eu fui dar bom dia eu
falei ladybug acredito agora quer achar
um lugar mais quente do que você tá
achando quente e entrar dentro de um
carro que Está estacionado do sol quente
ah Ave Maria meu amigo você abre a porta
do carro parece que tá entrando em
Teresina passa meia hora fazendo assim
ah Ave Maria não tem quem aguento não
meu amigo espera aí espera aí até agora
não espera aí espera aí liga o carro o
carro faz
ah liga o ar condicionado ar
condicionado
você Liga o rádio tá tocando Lady Gaga
baixa os vidros não aguento mais
calor do Satanás